so I've been getting sort of two
questions that are kind of related but
they're also separate questions about
Democrats and the future and this is a
good opportunity to kind of talk about
both and the two questions have been
what should the Democratic platform be
and what should the Democratic agenda be
and they might sound like they're the
same thing but they're not because when
I hear what should the Democratic agenda
be that means for me once Democrats take
over the house from 2019 to 2021 right
that that two-year period what should
the priorities be of Democrats in the
house Democratic platform means what
should be the campaign platform for 2020
there's a lot of overlap between those
two things but they're not actually the
same thing so listen breaking news
I'm a pragmatist and I want to win and
when I think about something like a
platform or an agenda I think not only
about what I like it's not just creating
a list of things that would be a
progressive paradise but that's not
totally realistic in a vacuum so I also
think about what would work politically
we need to find balance and there's a
lot of people in the audience who don't
like that about me who say Oh pragmatic
David Pakman is ignoring the fact that
XYZ is simply not progressive well yeah
I think we've got to find balance so
between idealism and pragmatism you need
some combination of aspirational big
ideas but also things you can do so you
can actually chalk up some
accomplishments and justify getting
elected again getting elected getting
reelected there's a balance between
policy that will appeal to the base and
bringing in people from the right and
middle to vote for you you've got to
understand what issues are voting issues
so where I immediately start is number
one infrastructure no-brainer we need to
fix things even Trump wanted
infrastructure he wanted to do it in a
total crony capitalist hand out corrupt
way but it's going to tie up Republicans
if all of a sudden
they're against infrastructure they'll
come up with some way to explain why the
way Trump wanted to do it is good and
the way Democrats want to do it is bad
but make them play that game so
infrastructure has to be there it also
provides jobs we have to fix bridges and
airports in our electrical grid they're
a total joke it'll help the construction
industry and its demand side stimulus
number two there should be a fiduciary
rule created that makes the relationship
between clients and their financial
advisors more like that with lawyers
period okay there will be arguments
against this but this should be done and
it's a sort of backdoor to solve lots of
current issues in the financial world
without doing like a financial
transaction tax which we should have by
the way but it's just a more complicated
thing to do that's something that that
should definitely be done and it should
be part of the Democratic agenda between
now and 2021 what about the minimum wage
I think the answer is obviously yes but
this is controversial and you will see
people on the right who say oh well what
did they strawman us with with why don't
make why don't we make the minimum wage
100 bucks an hour to 500 bucks an hour
it's just more money for everybody right
no one who is serious about the minimum
wage is suggesting that we're talking
about a modest increase to the minimum
wage it's good for employees it's good
for the economy right now the federal
minimum wage is still 725 an hour it's a
joke okay this is about fourteen
thousand five hundred dollars full time
per year for a 50 week work year set up
50 to 75 percent incremental increases
and let's start boosting it no one can
argue that that's crazy and you're going
to start moving in the direction we
ultimately want to go fighting climate
change in a serious manner there is no
economic or moral argument against this
period if cities go underwater it's
terrible for everybody if people die
from heat waves it's bad for everybody
infrastructure connects to this because
much of replacing old building
with efficient new ones and replacing
old electrical with new electrical it's
good for climate change and it's good
for the economy and then we get to
health care where the big question among
some on the left is do Democrats make
single-payer part of the platform or not
the answer for me is very simple yes do
it
stop being afraid every other country in
the developed world does it don't be
afraid it's not a government takeover of
health care it's a government takeover
of health insurance which is a terrible
industry you don't hate your doctor you
hate how the relationship with your
doctor has been perverted by for-profit
insurance companies start from that as a
negotiating point and negotiate from
there because you probably in the next
two years you're gonna have to negotiate
net neutrality no question you've got to
at least propose something specific on
campaign finance reform I understand a
lot of Democrats in power don't want to
change the system just like Republicans
don't want to change the system because
this is the system that brought them to
power in the first place but let's do
something whether it's unpack money or
public financing of Elections figure
something out and then voter suppression
call it the full vote initiative I don't
know I'm just thinking to call it the
full vote initiative this would include
fixing the Voting Rights Act which was
gutted dealing with voter suppression
tactics the details would need to be
figured out but the full vote initiative
must be part of the Democratic agenda
and then lastly what about guns the
issue with guns is that it may not be a
voting issue it may alienate voters so I
want at minimum as I as I punch my
microphone and I apologize a full we
need full background checks for all
transactions and we need gun insurance
like a car we need to think about the
pragmatism though does that alienate
people bill scher has talked to us about
the impact of gun gun safety regulations
in influencing voters those are on the
list for me certainly for the Democratic
agenda and in addition to that for the
Democratic platform going forward
what's missing where am i wrong let me
know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman one of
today's sponsors is privacy comm slash
Pakman this is a free service that I've
actually been using myself for a while
now and I love it
you just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
coms mobile app or browser extension for
Firefox and Chrome and what that does is
allow you to instantly create virtual
credit cards that are linked to your
bank account so that you're not actually
putting your real debit card number on
the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card
so a company won't be able to charge you
more than you actually want them to and
it protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below